[Music]
Disney thinks they can sneak some
narration pass me by singing it these
seagulls flying overhead were drawn here
because they have a keen sense of when
history is being made also just to be
clear there were three ships not just
one the discovery the Godspeed and the
Susan constant here's a guy who often
has to tell people my eyes are up here
fellas
are you coming on this voice Joe how is
this new information also who knew John
Smith was a Dolce & Gabana model I love
watching Disney history that's right I'm
not about to let you boys have all the
fun
Mel Gibson using his patented Australian
American accent for an English character
here's the thing storms just don't creep
up on ships sailors would be able to see
you when they would be nearing a storm
would prepare ya here they are
scrambling with the sails mid storm even
through these extreme winds these guys
upon the mast are not falling to their
deaths being able to hear that well from
that far away in a massive storm also
the smallest guy on the ship was able to
stop this extremely heavy cannon from
moving any further excessive
swashbuckling also John Smith must also
have the same rope burn resistant skin
that kept Tarzan's hands and feet safe
during his movie well here's an unholy
bullsh that I don't even need to check
the history books about John Smith
Aquaman you can find long sailors at
night on stormy seas using his telepathy
powers and fish Twitter also since this
voyage is happening in the winter I'm
going to guess this movie ends right
here with both of these guys dying of
hypothermia is the villainous Governor
John Radcliffe I could spot him anywhere
with his trademark purple outfit and
snobby pug dog just like in all the
paintings starring orations huh this guy
I'll need those witless peasants to dig
up my gold governor Ratcliffe wasn't
going to the New World for gold
he was partnering with John Smith to
remove Edward Wingfield from that you
know what I'm just gonna add 10 cents
for the loose interpretation of history
throughout this movie leave the savages
to me the native tribes were strong and
were known for scalping people and John
Smith thinks he can tackle an entire
tribe
or maybe two or three it's weird I could
kicked out of all the parties I attend
when I start any song this way John
Smith pokes a liquor barrel for
free-flowing booze but more than half
the booze will be on deck by the time
this is over I mean this is a colossal
waste of on roughly translated these
lyrics say another glorious day without
European settlers back in 1607 corn
fields were populated by nothing but
beautiful women the only recognizable
human moment in the entire film this
everyone is Pocahontas she was a runway
model who was highly adept at 20th
century makeup a leap that should put
her in the cliff-diving record books I
wonder she and Smith hit it off they
both have weird jumping powers also this
giant leap off a cliff gives surface
tension the finger the raccoon and
hummingbird dead right this is working
for me Oh Disney makes rodents of the
night that eat our garbage cute and
potentially encourages kids everywhere
to want one as a pet
come on flick Pocahontas has amazing
dead bird finding skills that person's
fist made a perfect bear paw print this
movie is anti nipple for men and anti
nose for the women now I've been having
a very strange dream I think it's
telling me somethings about to happen
something exciting or something is
terrible is a bunch of white men coming
bringing war and disease one of the two
I imagine that all this extra flit and
Miko slapstick was added after the first
screening of the film because they
realized how boring all this is even the
wild mountain stream must someday join
the big river as the river cuts his path
movie is finding any excuse to start
singing when movie is wrong man her jump
scare resistance is on point what is the
fascination Disney has with all the
wildlife in an area being attracted to
the local princess and their songs
I mean being kind and good is one thing
being Doctor Dolittle is another they
all survive this because kocoum doesn't
have actual nipples his bare paws just
look like giant nipples
does everyone get to talk to the genius
tree or only Pocahontas visit possible
she ate some berries that she wasn't
supposed to eat oh it free let's hear
all about who invited these person
Disney overload this fog is threatened
by the street even though the only part
of it that can move is its face seems to
this spinning hours pointing you down
your path grandmother willow was foolish
and also carpenter ants your mother
asked me the very same question what did
you tell her to listen then she died
with your heart well that settles it dad
I talked to the willow down the river
and it's sang to me to follow my heart
so I'm not marrying Coco um based on
deciduous tree advice fresh fruit
flowers on months long sea voyage King
James sees the gold these peasants on
earth
success will be mine at last this line
rating killed five animators I've never
seen anything like it
they have coastlines and forests in
England Thomas you got to get out of
London more we didn't come all this way
just to look at it we came all this way
to get out
funny that Disney decided not to talk
about how John Smith was charged with
mutiny on this trip but hey may need
this guy to kill savages so I guess he
was given a pass getting a better look
disappearing gun and that's the story of
how Pocahontas thought John Smith had a
hot butt I can forgive John Smith for
not wondering why this nocturnal animal
is running around in the daytime because
they aren't native to England but I'm
definitely wondering it you got a friend
back there is John used to this type of
friendly animal very back home
smoke movies that's the wrong flag the
red X representing Ireland wouldn't be
added until 1801 and there's no reason
to make that mistake since they already
used the right one for 1607 at the
beginning of the movie this fucking
raccoon just found a tree that somehow
hangs over the ship just so he can get
into some high jinks and it makes me
angry never trust a guy who can store
eight shovels in his cape they've been
here for two minutes in this irrigation
system is already here it's and I don't
one vine out of nowhere attached another
this multi-tiered mountain of digging
sailors looks inefficient for generally
most purposes John can hold water in his
hands long enough to properly examine an
impossible reflection Luca Hannes is
conveniently hot so John doesn't shoot
her it's damn impressive that his
matchlock musket was able to stay lit
after hopping through that waterfall you
don't understand a word I'm saying do
you know people who speak different
languages tend not to understand one
another this is what happens when
attractive people touch for the first
time
[Music]
language barriers solved with WillowTree
music magic Pocahontas and John Smith
now create a swirling barrier of some
sort that keeps all holy people out my
name is Pocahontas did she just speak
English even though she's never heard
any live before now or am I just
understanding her language suddenly or
Disney just phone this movie it
Ratcliff shoots one of these warriors
and what appears to be his knee but he
comes down grabbing his hamstring shot
in the back of the leg with a magic
curving bullet and then this guy decides
I've got this gun how about I try
beating him with it John Savage
acceptance level has gone through the
roof after a quick meeting with
Pocahontas it is not widely known that
hummingbirds are the cock blockers of
the animal kingdom compass it tells you
how to find your way when you get lost
but it's alright I'll get another one in
London there's no way I'll need it while
I'm here we've improved the lives of
savages all over the world citation
needed let go no I'm not letting you
leave even in a romantic whitewashed
children's movie John Smith is basically
history's biggest creep John Smith only
gets minor round she's from this you
think I'm an ignorant Savage you know
you've done that when someone sings
their argument to you mama bear does it
repeatedly mom Pocahontas for stealing
one of her cubs to show to a white dude
she definitely hasn't fed it and that
was the birth of the Cheshire Cat can
you paint with all the colors of the
wind
that sounds nice but it's complete
nonsense at least circle of life
admitted that animals get eaten neither
of their arms are severely gashed by
these large birds of praise talents at
leisure Pocahontas didn't feed Smith any
mushrooms before this musical number
because that would explain a lot movie
thinks it can just throw Pride Rock into
itself and it will be as good as Lion
King jeez this song started off with
Pocahontas saying you're an awful person
but by the end of it they're almost
kissing this is sending me mixed
messages that will destroy my college
years
please don't leave I'm sorry huh usually
my blond-haired blue-eyed trick works in
these situations we shot ourselves an
engine or maybe two or three John
bristles from that song now because he
knows Indians have the capability of
being attractive dougie bone kara so
what am i overlooking well Virginia's
not on that map for one it's a goal they
have it and they don't want us to take
it from them why would the governor
think the savages have any interest in
gold moose in coastal Virginia jeez
that's the heaviest biscuit ever made
and if so flit is dead and to think we
came all this way just to dig it up for
gold go Pocahontas is unsure what gold
is despite knowing fluent English and
all its nuances through tree sorcery
what was that I'm fairly certain now
that this movie is just a giant John
Smith drug trick it's amazing that John
gets to experience all the wonders of
the new world just because he befriended
Pocahontas and is less terrible than all
the other people he came with my bark is
worse than my bite Hey else that's my
job he has a good soul apparently an
epic Burning Man experience with a hot
girl cancels out a lifetime of murdering
natives in the name of adventure these
two guys quickly happened upon Smith
even though he is deep in the forest I
want to see him again wouldn't I want to
see him again that's enough of the horny
old willow tree is a sentence I never
thought would need saying yet here we
are Oh John I could have killed you not
I mean like that you couldn't not a
Thomas survived long enough to even make
it to America he sucks at everything but
this is their land said no colonists
ever what do you see they had corn in
England during this time right
Pocahontas please you're my best friend
I don't want you to get hurt this is why
Disney heroes usually only have animal
friends
smart humans will try to talk you out of
whatever dangerous heroes you're about
to engage it what about them so small at
first
then look how they grow you see water
ripples are a lot like telling your
racist friends not to attack a group of
people who aren't like that so they're
the guy who's in love with John Smith
and the guy who was in love with
Pocahontas just happened to stumble on
them making out at the same time my foot
throws a whole bunch of guns to his men
and they all miraculously catch one
man-made smoke that looks like clowns
clash into each other and create
lightning good of the tribe to leave an
easy path for Pocahontas so she can
block this execution the story of
Pocahontas saving Smith from execution
came from John Smith himself John Smith
also had a story about being bought as a
slave and his master sent him as a
present to his favorite Greek mistress
Smith said that the mistress fell in
love with him so let's just say we've
got an unreliable narrator at best looks
like John Smith's boner was caught
between a rock and a hard place I love
him father we sang and danced for a
couple days that's the longest
relationship I've ever been in invisible
bullit and that's how the local native
tribes were forced to give all their
food to the inept settlement yet what
pain I've had worse pain than this I
heard that even in a cartoon Mel Gibson
needed to suffer in the movie some way
or else he wouldn't done this I thought
she didn't like strangers I was gonna
send this moment for John saying flit
still thinks of him as a stranger after
all this time but then I remembered a
grown man is talking to a hummingbird
and for some reason the dog is no longer
an asshole but the pain cuz it's free is
she sending him magic from the forest
I'll always love you now here's some
leaves and nothing bad happened between
Native Americans and colonists ever
again
of efficient left the bondage in your
mood and stalls Guetta feat affair right
here on for this damn right here what
were you doing up there
I'm just sitting up here thinking you
know Oh mountains
I love go Marin's just it's a piece of
paper well I'm throwing it's the way one
said I love you
[Music]
I've got gadgets and gizmos aplenty
Robert Frost said two roads diverged in
a wood and I
I took the one less traveled by and that
has made all the difference if you
listen they will guide you if you build
it he will come
you think you own whatever land you land
on mega you can't claim as we live in
five hundred million of us do you have a
flag is there a kind of proposal I love
you always have one are you close that
one to you might suppose I ask you to
marry me what would you say are you
shrink from me why don't you say yes
this isn't what I expected